training he's a professor emeritus of
educational psychology and technology in
the rösler School of Education he's a
clinical research professor of surgery
in the Keck School of Medicine and
co-director of the Center for cognitive
technology at the University of Southern
California before coming to USC he was a
faculty member in psychology and
education at Stanford oh sorry um and
Syracuse University's he also served as
chief science advisor for expert
knowledge solutions LLC please join me
in welcoming Dick Clark good morning a
rainy morning Boston I I want to start
by telling you that the mission of the
center that I co-direct Valley Monroe at
USC is to look at research in various
fields collected together try to
summarize it and tease it into actual
answers and directions for people who
are trying to make decisions in
educational fields the technology and
cognition is the area that we tend to
specialize in so my goal today is to
describe some of that research to you
and to do it not in an if it may be this
or that or the other thing but to try to
bring it down to a bottom line in doing
so I'm probably going to offend some of
my colleagues in the audience who are
cognitive psychologists so I'll
apologize in advance but not very
seriously actually so with that in mind
here's the goal that I have today three
different topics I want to you know the
research is counter-intuitive often and
it's one of a one of the exciting things
about it's the thing that drew me into
it as a as an adolescent and so I want
to describe some of the counterintuitive
findings from research and i also want
to talk about some things that I think
we're typically doing in MOOCs and other
technology based education that actually
not only don't work but could actually
make learning much worse i also want to
talk about what i think that the best
evidence is about how to maximize
learning i want to talk about motivation
that M word that
it doesn't get mentioned very often but
it's absolutely critical in the work
that we do in MOOCs and i also want to
talk about what i think are the issues
that relate i want to focus my clock on
something that people call instructional
design that is that the the effort here
that has to do with how exactly do we
add instructional strategies to MOOCs
along with that great information that
comes from faculty members in order to
make learning possible for students and
i want to talk also about screen design
that is how do we tailor the screen the
graphic user interfaces the various
objects that are on screens in order to
make learning more effective and I talk
also about motivation strategies and fun
I want to talk a little bit about
research that needs to be done and
perhaps even suggest some questions that
are out there that are kind of crying
for answers so with that in mind here's
some of the places I'm taking evidence
from today I heard a number of people
yesterday asked are there ish are there
things i can read that would help me
understand learning and how to make it
happen i always want that when i go to a
different field i wish i could find a
book that would explain engineering or
particle physics or whatever else so i
could work in those fields it doesn't
usually happen with a book but there are
some that do a very nice job of a wreck
of summarizing some of this I
particularly want to recommend the book
by Ruth Clark and Richard Mayer which
elearning in the science of design it's
called appear actually Ruth Clark's no
relation Richard Mayer is the head of
psychology at UC Santa Barbara excellent
book nice summary of what's going on
there so with those things in mind I
want to talk about why I think it's
important to do evidence-based design in
MOOCs and I want to talk about what I
think universities are actually
accomplishing and learning when you look
at the data you get the sense at
universities may be about something but
a learning it may not be one of the most
critical goals that they have for
example here's a when we look at what
students learn about analytical skills
or critical thinking or the things that
we think are critical about universities
almost a half a two-year and a third of
for your students get no analytical
learning gains when compared to freshmen
who are entering the year that they
leave University with with the degree
those whose learning doesn't prove only
gained about 4% over their entry /
people that are entering that year they
remember less than thirty percent of
what they actually were asked to learn
in their courses here's something I find
interesting which is that prestige
colleges don't have any larger gains
than students and then colleges that are
on the bottom of the list stem students
are then talking a lot about stem
yesterday science technology engineering
mathematics there's they're quite their
skills actually seem to decline that is
their ability to write and to reason
about quantitative issues physics
students think less like physicists when
they leave minority and underserved
students actually do worse than
everybody else and here to me is the
money statement which is that the
faculty who always are excellent faculty
often people that are whose work is
prized have expertise in their
discipline but most actually don't have
pedagogical expertise lectures are not
teaching lectures are media for giving
information and it most of us the fact
that they lack pedagogical expertise
doesn't mean that always as faculty we
are under confident than about our
ability and willing to take advice we
tend to be overconfident and that
actually means that people who do know
something about learning who are
responsible for designing MOOCs are
either not able are not allowed to to
use this information as MOOCs are being
designed so one of the messages i'm
going to build into this is we've got to
be thinking about team's about
interdependent groups of teams doing
these this work and at the very least we
absolutely need the content expertise of
extraordinary faculty members we also
need people who are in decision roles
who can who know
something about learning and the design
of instruction to promote it and I
believe we need a third expertise also
because measurement and evaluation is
not something that most of us are
familiar with there are a number of
people here who have that expertise I
noticed them gently making suggestions
during talks yesterday and I noticed
they were largely ignored so there
really is a science there and there's a
technology and it needs to be
implemented in MOOCs so with that in
mind here's some also some
counterintuitive research evidence
things that we're using that don't work
and I won't i took out of the talk what
both of the previous keynotes mentioned
which is the learning styles literature
which is their only individual
differences that seem to make a
difference in learning reliably our
intelligence and prior knowledge the
rest of these verbal learning verbal you
know visual learners things just don't
work but there are other things it's
important to know that media the choice
of technology does not influence
learning it does not sorry and and media
lectures are media video is media all
these things that we tend to first go to
to do experiments on learning in MOOCs
are not going to make any difference
it's something embedded in them that's
making a difference and what's embedded
in them is something that I call
instructional methods or instructional
strategies and that's defined as
external events that provide internal
cognitive processes that are required to
learn and I'd add to that that students
either can't or won't provide for
themselves so we actually embed learning
strategies in the instruction and
surround the information that comes from
from faculty members so that it's easier
for students to digest that information
to learn it to be able to transfer it
after they finish the courses media has
a huge impact and one of the great
benefits of MOOCs is that it provides
access to learning for a huge number of
people that's our whole goal it seems to
me is accessing we ought to be studying
that access more than we are and
secondly it
fluences the cost of learning yeah
presumably if it's amortized over
thousands of people it's a there's a
huge cost benefit but it actually can
turn out to be the more expensive way to
teach somebody something also so it's
also the case that and here's something
that's very not very well known but it's
been around for I don't know how many
years the quick way to say this is it
it's possible to make people more stupid
when you teach them in other words that
if you pre and post to the knowledge
that students have if you do pretest and
then post test them there is over 70 or
80 studies published in Nice journals
that actually demonstrate that people no
less after they finish instruction than
they did before when the instructional
strategy being used was just the worst
thing that for them so they're less able
to recall they're less able to remember
they're less able to use the knowledge
that they have that information
basically is in older journals it's not
there now because nobody publishes it
but at I see yesterday and one of the
research sessions somebody giving
negative correlations with learning for
certain things that went on in a MOOC
well that's an example of important
information that would probably not be
accepted and published in a journal
today which is means that journals
really need to rethink what they're
doing in science thirty percent of
students like instructional strategies
from which they learn the least if
they're given a choice they will
reliably choose what's worse for them so
student choice is not always the best
indicator of what students are going to
do when they learn so if you give them
choices it better be things where either
choice would have equal benefit for them
many moves give people an opportunity to
run through courses as they want it's
not a very good thing to do it actually
harms learning novice learners do not
benefit from immersive simulations and
games I'm sorry I know they can be very
motivating but the motivation comes it
costs the cost of learning which would
you rather have I hate this I don't like
it is not my preference but I know a lot
of us have the instinct if we only
transfer from games to move
that kind of wonderful motivation that
comes when people get into video games
we but the evidence is pretty powerful
the only contradiction to this is
research this produced by the people who
actually sell games here's another one
faculty are able to only describe thirty
percent of what they know that is their
analytical knowledge their decision
knowledge the analysis that they do is
largely automated and unconscious and
the evidence is powerful that while they
can do it and succeed at it consistently
they are not very accurate when they try
to describe it to somebody else that
causes problems when we do what's called
task analysis in the preparation to do
these courses the worst not the
information is that faculty often invent
things that might accomplish the goal
that they that they so reliably
complished themselves and those
inventions are often wrong the evidence
is not how it could be done it's not
even how it is done I work in surgery
it's a very extraordinary of expertise
and when surgeons make mistakes is
pretty obvious and it's measurable and
has to be recorded by law and surgeons
are often extremely wrong when they tell
other surgeons and novice surgeons how
to do a surgery so they have to have
them do it in order to learn it that the
percent of students are wrong when you
ask them what they learn so if you're
going to evaluate learning by asking
people what they learn you're not going
to get a very reliable response so
what's the problem here why is it the
case that all these things are happening
why aren't we making more of a
difference in learning why is it that
we're using so many of these
counterintuitive things i want to go to
cognitive architectures on cognitive
architecture and neuroscience cure and i
think what's important is to notice that
learning maybe because of evolutionary
psychologists make all kinds of claims
but one that attracts me is that
learning is almost impossible for human
beings probably because if we learn
things fast we'd learn stupid stuff that
would be self-destructive so we have
evolved perhaps to make learning
difficult and one of the evidence of
evidence for that is that our thinking
space is extremely limited we used to
say so we can think about seven items at
once no no it's been revised its three
plus or minus
so we have three spaces to think in
three things that we can kind of
manipulate at one time it's almost
nothing stress and distractions take up
those spaces so as learners adults
children doesn't matter we are more or
less at sort of faced with the fact that
we've got to focus very carefully on
what it is that we want to learn in
order to learn it when we overload our
thinking space it crashes whoever had to
read a chapter for the next day and you
want to do something and you know I got
all this stuff to read I want to be done
by nine o'clock I'm going to watch
television want to go to a movie
whatever it is started to read looked at
the clock at seven o'clock and all of a
sudden you look at the clock again and
it's seven-thirty and you don't know
what you've read and what happens is
that you crashed your cognition crashes
and it's a pleasurable experiences to
evidence so the more that we hos
students with information the more
likely it is that they'll crash the more
likely it is that those crashes actually
may cause patrols so we have to be very
careful about how much information we
present at any one given time I want to
actually make the point that there are
some strategies to focus people's
attention on important things and to
provide instructional methods that
actually work for them and that do not
overload their working memory if you
want to read some of this literature
John sweller at the University of South
Wales as a wonderful book on cognitive
load theory it's called a terrific stuff
I'm going to describe some of it
learning a motivation are difficult
because we have two knowledge systems
also the declarative knowledge system
which is conscious knowledge as learning
things like concepts and processes how
things work the definition of terms
principle scientific principles so on
facts all those things that you can
remember and spit back on an exam is
only one of the knowledge systems the
larger knowledge system is a procedural
system some people call it a production
system it is the system that automates
what we learn all of our application
knowledge is automated and it's
automated so it
escapes this limitation on thinking and
working memory our goal is to help
students actually apply the knowledge
that they learn in order to do that that
knowledge has to be presented in a way
that it's going to be easy for them to
take in and automate eventually so that
they can get on with our learning so
they continue to automate things as they
go along and what we're actually doing
in most mu construction and most
University instructions we're teaching
declarative knowledge we're not teaching
students how to procedural eyes that
knowledge so that they can apply it step
by step which means the decisions they
make analysis they do it's always a
combination of actions and decisions
that we do when we ever do we apply
anything and that is something we have
to think more about as teaching this
more procedural knowledge when it's
taught the evidence is that courses
ought to be designed in the sequence in
which that knowledge will be applied
later if we can determine what that
might be in other words the first lesson
autumn or the first part of a lesson
ought to be what person does first
second part second third and fourth if
there is no sequence than easier
information on it it's easier to learn
information ought to be taught before
more difficult I don't notice many
courses actually that are designed that
babe but when they are students learn so
much faster more importantly they
transfer and apply that knowledge so
much more quickly lessons ought to be
designed around an application of some
kind a decisions learning how to make
decisions learning how to solve problems
whatever it is and all the knowledge
that's presented in that lesson Otto
surround to how to knowledge so all the
declarative knowledge now there's new
concepts laws principles all those
things ought to be taught in reference
to application knowing when you do again
it automates more quickly students store
the conscious knowledge sort of in
reference to the more conceptual
knowledge the more procedural applied
knowledge that they learn and so on so
if we're going to do this
what would the framework for
instructional design look like what's an
ideal framework based on the evidence
that's out there let me go there next I
want to point out and shout out about
the work that's going on at Carnegie
Mellon and the University of Pittsburgh
learn lab the Pittsburgh science of
learning center I think is probably one
of the best centers in the country doing
this work in technology they have a
publication that I want to recommend to
everybody it's on the lower left-hand
side of the screen it's in cognitive
science and it's a Kenko dagur and his
colleagues produced a description of the
framework that they have to describe
both knowledge types and ways to teach
them and I think it's an excellent thing
they talk about instructional events and
assessment events and you'll notice in
this Venn diagram that this the shared
set between the two is fairly large in
other words assessment is another kind
of instructional method it when it's
done well it performs two functions it
not only tells you how students are
learning as they progress but it also
helps them learn the more they're tested
the more they have to recall the more
they have to apply knowledge the more
quickly they learn it more quickly they
automate it the more quickly they're
willing they're able to go on to
something else they also use this same
definition for instructional methods or
instructional events external support
for internal cognitive processing they
make it they talk a lot about the fact
that the problem here for many people
with sciences is it's so much of
cognition is not directly observable it
has caused considerable problem not only
in all of the profession also in
psychology and yet we have to make
inferences about what goes on
cognitively and they have ways to do
that I think that are excellent John
Anderson's work here we are again in
Pittsburgh is extraordinary because John
has actually made an attempt to combine
the work in cognitive science in the
work in neuroscience John's Theory talks
about a number of cognitive modules that
he's found that he feels are activated
and have to be supported during learning
and so this sequence that you see
there's a sequence of modules that
operate in his view Wednesday
learn something they have to have an
objective they have to have reasons for
learning in other words they have that
motivation to actually invest effort pay
attention to something an overview they
need connections to put what is this
like that I already know connections to
prior knowledge they need conceptual
knowledge declarative knowledge for
example that we were talking about they
need to have how to do something
demonstrated for them step by step they
need to be challenged to practice it and
apply it and while they challenge and
apply it they need corrective feedback
so they don't learn it wrong unlearning
things is two to three times as
difficult as learning it the first time
and unlearning happens very fast if
you're not corrected with feedback when
you go off the track here's another
version of this slight is just almost
the same just a little bit more explicit
for a design objective what will be
learned the benefit and risk of that an
outline of what's going to happen and
how it's going to be taught connections
to prior knowledge through things like
analogies and metaphors conceptual
knowledge the concepts that are related
to what you're going to learn how to do
and apply in this lesson then a
demonstration about when and how you do
it and then feedback that helps correct
that learning what I find exciting about
it is that this kind of results in the
research let me be quiet let you read
you notice not only does learning
increase but also that the number of
errors people commit decreases that the
time that it takes them to learn
decreases we actually increase
instructional time a bit with these
strategies but the benefit is that
student learning happens much faster
since we don't value students learning
fast we don't assess it and it's
difficult to talk people into that as an
approach but it does make a huge
difference we have better assessment
targets we know how to assess learning
when we use these approaches much better
and
it's in fact much more motivating for
students when we do this even though
it's not so motivating for faculty
because it really requires a lot more
effort and design now I want to make a
transition from talking about
instruction that should be the case no
matter what the field no matter what
discipline no matter who's being trained
to do 12 how what do we know about
screen design about that visual
description that visual plan for the
screen in a MOOC and here I'm going to
draw very heavily on the work of two
people rich mayor at UC Santa Barbara
and John sweller and Australia and I
wanted to say that this is very
international research this is not in
the English language lurk necessarily
this data comes from a huge variety of
cultures and countries so what rich has
done is generate a number of principles
i want to quickly describe 10 of them
and i want you to notice that they're
how they're organized on the screen it
says students learn better when and then
there's a percent mark the percent mark
is how much more learning occurs when
this principle is implemented and how
many tests have been done at different
laboratories that have come up with them
information that allows for the a2
squared the variance accounted for that
leads into the percentage increase ok so
here they are I'll be quiet let you take
a look at
can I call your attention to the first
one to me this is a this is a really
important one which is that the more
that we eliminate all of the extraneous
stuff on a screen no music nothing that
distract students none of those cute you
know animated figures that run around
the screen and point of stuff and all
these things that we can do the
technology is capable of doing but that
if we do it we merely distract students
stay away from it as the evidence the
cleaner the need are the more Spartan
that screen the more it focuses directly
on the learning objective and what
students need to know the more quickly
they pick it up the less they're
distracted the less they become
cognitively overloaded here's another
five
it amazes me how much it helps to just
simply ask students to imagine an
experience they've had that is like
something they're going to learn when
when when Meryl Earthman mayor teaches
students something about lightning he
asked them to imagine the last time they
saw lightning when he does that look how
the learning jumps it's pretty it's
pretty astounding but apparently what
happens is that when you ask students a
question like that and you personalize
their experience their mind then rings
up all of the information they've stored
connected to the topic they're going to
learn something about and when that
happens the information that comes in is
now stored adjacent to what they already
know so when they're retrieving that
knowledge they're not only retrieving
what they just learned an instruction
there are also retrieving the related
knowledge which is reinforcing it
elaborating it and making it much more
easy for them to integrate with what
they already know i mean the concern is
that when we don't do this students can
learn things but they isolate it and
that interconnectedness is something
that while highly intelligent people do
it naturally because of right there's a
variation in the intelligence and the
prior knowledge of the people we're
teaching and we are very much helping
people that do not have are not in the
what top 1% of the ability distribution
who do not have a huge preparation for
university work to remember and to be
able to use what we teach I've only
given 10 here mayor has a number of
books where he goes much further this he
gives great examples of them till she
shows you how to design to achieve each
one of these principles i really want to
suggest his work it's extraordinary now
i want to spend a few minutes talking
about motivation this is the topic that
almost never gets discussed and part of
it is because motivation in the in the
world today most of the people do
research on motivation are very
fragmented it's for a variety of
historical reasons it's a relatively new
area 15 to 20 years or more recent
theories of motivation whereas in
learning we've been working for 150
years it stopped after the behavioral
era for a very long time people felt
they solve the problem of motivation
they didn't and so when it started up
again it started up in a fragmented way
so I want to try to bring it together
because I think there's a current
approach that's very promising for us
it's called expectancy value theory and
it looks like this it makes the
assumption that all motivation at its
base is comes from our experience and
belief about what makes us effective
what gives us control what makes us
successful and when it when we when we
connect with that we always do in order
to decide what are we going to pay
attention to what are we going to invest
effort in and here's the sequence that
these people talk about first of all on
the left our past experience of
effectiveness leads us to make four
kinds of decisions that are critical for
variables that over and over again turn
up to be extremely predictive of
people's motivation and those are the
value that we give to whatever it is
we're doing our confidence that we can
actually learn and that if we learn we
will be permitted to use what it is
we're learning this is a big deal by the
way for minorities who while they may
have confidence they can learn something
are not terribly certain they're going
to be allowed to use it minorities and
women to I suspect and in all countries
there are minorities that have this
issue third attributions in other words
our belief about what causes us to
succeed or fail particularly what causes
us to have difficulties as we're
learning is it something that's
controllable or not is the issue if we
feel we can't control the source of fit
our failures during the time we learn
we're not going to be motivated to
continue so we have to always believe
students have to always be encouraged to
believe it no matter what happens to
them if they just invest or effort they
will succeed and in a world Carolyn
dweck is the person here I think we all
look to for for insights about this
Carolyn's view is that we teach our
children that intelligence is the only
important thing so when they fail they
feel it's an indicator they're not smart
enough and so
should they continue if we teach
children instead that effort is what
determines their success then failure is
a message that they need to work harder
and if they should be where they are in
other words if they really are have the
prior knowledge and to succeed in the
course then that is a true statement and
that's what they have to focus on
finally neuro scientists tell us that
emotions are always active when people
are learning now there is no Spock in us
it's like we're always emotional and
when emotions are extremely negative
motivation stops so depression or anger
are two things that really kill
motivation for everybody so those four
variables now tend to feed into and
predict the three things that
characterize motivation starting
something as opposed to intending
secondly invest persisting at it once
that we start which by the way is the
biggest problem for everybody these
three and the third is actually
investing mental effort you know the
third one which we think will mental
effort of course we're always going to
work to learn know if you are
overconfident about what you're seeing
which some students are and believe
they're going to learn it no matter what
they're not going to work very hard
they're going to use what they already
know and think it'll work and the worst
thing about overconfidence is that when
somebody is overconfident and they fail
they don't take responsibility it's the
program it's their faculty member its
whatever it's caused their failure and
that's not a very productive assumption
so here are strategies then based on
these that actually make a difference
keep in mind that for psychologists in
motivation these three things
characterize mode these are the
dependent measures that we should be
measuring do they start do they persist
and do the investment 11 and there are
ways to measure all three by the way I'm
going to show you some of them so the
instructional strategies I'm going to
find a way to give personal value can I
make the point here I heard a number of
people this yesterday asked the question
about different cultures because well I
don't think there are many cultural
differences in
name there are huge cultural differences
in motivation we all have the same
cognitive architecture we all have the
same brain we haul by the same
mechanisms for learning but we have very
different views about value that are
culturally based so students that are
not persisting often need value secondly
task-specific confidence it's called
self-efficacy here we I think most of us
looked at albert bandura's work and
self-efficacy a wonderful book called
self-efficacy a decade or so and under
and over confidence decrease both
persisting and more importantly mental
effort people that are under confident
won't invest effort because they think
why I'm going to fail anyway people that
are overconfident don't invest effort
because they think they already know it
and both of them are in trouble if they
don't know it a positive emotional
climate I don't know what that means in
a MOOC setting but it could be that
intermittent games for example might put
people in a very positive vein while it
may not teach them anything it might
actually help them relax from some work
that they've done get them in greengage
get them excited and then hit them with
more instruction afterwards you know a
very successful program that was
international that was developed in a
collaboration between instructional
designers faculty and media people which
we've all gotten about now we don't talk
about it anymore maybe the most
successful thing it was ever done in the
world Sesame Street actually use these
strategies they had something they call
pixilation it worked with kids whenever
they give some ask kids do a lot of work
in math or reading or our letter
identification or something they do
these funny little things but danced
around on the screen just to kind of
entertain them and then they'd hit them
with something really hard again we need
to pixelate in MOOCs baby finally asking
students to rethink or reframe their
beliefs about how controllable the
problems they're having are when they
encounter them in a MOOC and and and
give them feedback that it's more effort
that's required
I know people don't love to hear that
but that's the feedback people needed we
need to give it in a way that's
acceptable to people so those things
again i want to say vary enormously
between cultures so if you try to build
into a probe into a MOOC things that you
think are going to create value or
efficacy or whatever else for everybody
forget it these are things that really
need to be local and I think their ways
to do that here's I'm using us a I
really am impressed with the work that's
going on at Kaplan University it's a
it's a for-profit university owned by
The Washington Post I think they own the
corporation anyway and they have really
tried to build in to their online work
the monitoring the constant monitoring
and intervening and motivation here's an
example of the kind of thing they do
there are questionnaires that have been
found through reliably and with good
predictive validity measure each one of
these four variables they insert them
into instruction particularly when
students are having difficulty and they
use the result of that to actually
modify what students see next I realize
that many of the LMS systems that
present MOOCs this is just not possible
so my suggestion is we need to start
rethinking the design of lms systems so
that they reflect what we need to do in
pedagogy rather than to have the tail
wagging the dog in other words the
limitations of our pedagogy being the
limitations of the lms system thank you
from your hands to the ears of the
people that design these things another
thing actually that that Kaplan does
that I'm very attracted to is that they
use checklists for their designers
checklists that faculty and designers
and measurement people and so on can
share the results of as the design is
progressing before it gets to the point
where we've invested all the money
required in order to develop these
materials now if you find a problem here
now you can go and talk about it and by
the way back to Sesame Street I started
out there as a graduate student so I
keep coming
long ago actually the life any school
but I remember that when we had
differently had disagreements among
ourselves when students weren't doing
well in the drafts of the things that we
pre-tested who made the final decision
the students did we went out and
pretested we had groups of kids that
actually were test subjects and we ran
by the different alternatives that were
going to use to try to solve the
problems we had and it wasn't the
strongest talker it wasn't somebody who
was in charge or who's managing it was
our prototype students who decided were
strategy would take as we went into the
development stage if we can do that we'd
have much more products out here so now
back to they were down to talking a bit
about the research on MOOCs well I've
had some very negative things to say
about the things we're doing that are
not working that are counterproductive
the research findings that are
counterintuitive and so on I also want
to say that I think the hope for
understanding more about learning rests
entirely with you I do not believe that
the system we have in universities to do
research is functioning all that well oh
yes it's terrific and its really managed
by bright people but excuse me a year
and a half to do one study this is not
acceptable this takes way too long where
as you all know that in this environment
studies can be done in a blink of an eye
and we can get we can do many different
tests of single single variables and
start adding variables we can have many
students experience these things we can
give very rapid feedback and hopefully
not only improve the design of the
course that we're developing but also
add to our knowledge about learning and
learning with a technology like the
computer so what kinds of questions
ought to be asking I don't want to
actually present all of them i just want
to point out to you so Ken coated or
invincibly even have made a list of
things that they think would be great
questions to ask now this list was 06
which is a long time ago but it's still
very relevant in my view and before i
present it can i say just one thing it's
a very wasteful thing
to do research to spend the time and the
effort without actually mastering prior
research in the area where you're asking
a question don't all fields teach that
and an education I think it's the same
there people approach it often as if
nothing is known and I'm going to invent
something brand-new and in 150 years
with some fairly bright Bo I understand
education is a bottom feeder in the
universities and status and so I'm a
believer not there are people who are
extremely bright and capable who have
the missionary zeal to actually work
there and they've done some
extraordinary work and you really need
to learn it before you take the next
step and try to ask some questions
because it'll save you an enormous
amount of time and it will greatly
increase the value of what it is that
you do so here's the here's the thing
they want to use they want us obviously
to use data mining and they're talking
about five things that they think that
are very big issues that are being
discussed out there should we have a way
to choose content based on prior
knowledge what students already know and
so start students out at different there
are different parts of a MOOC or
indifferent MOOCs different courses
sorry secondly there's a still an
argument about how much guidance we have
to give students for example when we
demonstrate how to make decision should
we demonstrate everything that they have
to do or should we leave some stuff out
for them to discover and invest for
themselves I fall on the former side and
I've argued for that but I deeply
respect colleagues who fall on the other
side there are also questions here about
what's called a problem first approach
where you give people a problem let them
struggle with it then show them how to
do it I don't think that's an
instructional strategy I think that's a
motivational strategy that gets people
engaged in a question gets them focused
on it helps them value it because
they've not done well at it and it but
but it's still another issue to take a
look at immediate or delayed feedback
holy moly this questions been around for
what 50 years and there's still people
that get all hot and bothered about it
there's there's a couple of really good
current reviews of when feedback needs
to be given
in MOOCs we almost never give feedback
to students or if we do is just about
their memory for concepts basically in
multiple choice ways okay fine but the
question is how fast should it be given
immediate or delayed and actually I if
you look at the research here you'll
find that people that talk about delayed
feedback or actually talking about a
matter of minutes not months or days or
weeks nobody i think makes the claim
that waiting a week or so to give
students feedback is productive at all
and yet that's probably the most typical
time frame providing or asking for
explanations this is new stuff but it's
very exciting asking students to explain
and by the way you don't have to listen
to their explanation pull down menus
with alternative explanations are just
as effective as listening to them and
judging what explanation they give
provided those pulldown menus have a
variety of explanations that are typical
of what might come from students at that
level and then when a student gets stuck
do you let them struggle or do you hint
well there may be instances where each
are valuable but we don't know enough
about that right now no this is only
five types of questions each one of them
has resulted from a very careful look at
what's out there in the research there
are many more obviously but the bottom
line here is it's better to actually
master the history of a question that
leads up to the one you want to ask
rather than starting from scratches if
nobody does that question before so here
i am at the end and i want to make just
a few closing points the focus is on
learning or should be there's no L in
Luke but it's what it's about it's what
they're all about that design requires
very defective and collaborative work
between three different specialties
minimum and all those specialties have
to have the responsibility to control
the decision in their area this to me
would make more of a difference in
almost anything we're doing and yet to
me also it's going to be the most
difficult to implement I've been trying
myself to do this different
universities over a very newark number
of years and most of those efforts fail
on this basis and they fail because one
or the other of these groups take over
and want to control we've got to learn
to collaborate this is not the 15th
century anymore this is not that
everybody's one person's in charge you
know the rule of the chalk is one of my
colleagues calls it the rule of the
front of the room faculty have to be
willing to give up some of their control
over the outcome in order to make the
results for students more effective
guided pedagogy and avoiding cognitive
load this the sequence for course design
and the sequencing of lessons and of
course is what we're calling now guided
designer guided pedagogy and designing
the screen so that people on overload
and crash is another critical issue here
diagnosing and treating motivation
problems online be trying to think
carefully about if these courses are
going to different cultures what value
statement what reason for doing it is
going to be effective with the greatest
number of students in the greatest
number of settings this course is going
to that's the really cut risk because
you really have to describe to students
what they risk if they don't learn what
what's being taught in a particular
lesson also LMS systems have to change
to accommodate the pedagogy that we need
to succeed with learning and research to
prove instruction must be based on a
thorough review of solid past studies
and I emphasize solid because in a field
like education there's a lot of stuff
out there published that isn't worth the
paper that it's written on I'm sorry but
it's true and that's maybe why it is
that it's not a more effective field all
right that's it thank you very much
novices simulations might not be best
for novices and I'm wondering if there's
any caveats there particularly with
respect to your point about the
procedural knowledge not being taught as
well my intuition is that novices would
benefit from simulations for learning
procedural knowledge I think the issue
here is what kind of simulation how much
how rich does it have to be on the
screen with things that might distract
students and I don't want to discourage
simulations but I said immersive I use
the term immersive simulation which is
the term that not everybody uses but it
means that you're totally into the
you're invited to kind of come into a
digital world so to speak and experience
something that has all kinds of issues
that may be extremely distracting to
students whereas simulations that are
more downscale and more focused on
exactly how to do something are highly
productive and helpful thank you for
that question it's an important
distinction hi thank you over here thank
you very much for that talk and as
somebody from the education world I very
much appreciate your reminding people
that there's a long history of research
and knowledge that we have gained I was
just curious about one thing when you
were talking about motivation and
attribution to intelligence or effort
one of the things that's been found
certainly in North American cultures I
think is that women tend to attribute
their success or failure more to work
their own work and men tend to provide
more attribution to their own innate
intelligence and I was wondering if you
could comment on how that might play
into things that there are gender
differences in attributional patterns
and different cultures is at the point
yes yeah there are and actually they are
quite different in different cultures
and I think actually if we're going to
collaborate with people from different
cultures we really have to look
carefully at what the patterns of things
like value
attributional styles and those sorts of
things are and the cultures where we
want to have the biggest impact and what
it implies to me is that while the same
instruction is probably going to work
different cultures the motivational
overlay from that instruction the
motivational if you do a diagnostic
system where you try to help students
who are not motivated who are stuck in
some fashion because of a motivational
problem we really have to be more
concerned about the culture that they're
in I don't know how we do that but I
think that's a future goal that we have
to look for I don't think of motivation
is something that's easy to build into a
course at the front end finding reasons
for people so you can create value
that's necessary I think even that's
chancy but it's better I think to think
of motivation is something that is
actually a diagnostic system that's
built into a program and you know it's
one of those if it's not broken don't
fix it but if it is broken have a way to
find that out do something about it at
least that's the best evidence right now
even though I realize that given the
technology that we have at the moment
that's not a very it's not very
optimistic about being able to implement
that they're effective way but we need
our minds on where we're going as well
as on how to fix where we are right on a
direct what you said what you said about
motivation somewhat made me a little
unhappy because one thing I have
observed over many years of teaching is
the most important things to teach
students is I don't know I don't know
everything sorry one of the most
important things in teaching eyes to me
is to tell the students I don't know
everything oh and that's very so the
argument that if you don't understand
what's going on it's your fault you
haven't worked hard enough bothers me
because what I my feeling here here is
that if I the students understand what
I'm talking about oh my fault I to me
that's very consistent and I think it's
a nice thing to for everybody to say
that that I have to invest effort also
as a faculty member not only when you're
teaching but when you're presenting in a
MOOC that that I have to I have to work
hard my field
continue but you don't have to work as
hard as they do actually your students
they're not expert that and you know by
the way all of the suggestions i made
for instruction are not true for experts
experts learning something don't need
any of this they just need problems and
resources and the motivation to address
them it's novices it's people who are
students who need it and that's part of
the problem of convincing faculty to use
these strategies that we over generalize
from our own memory of our own
experience and what we were generalized
is that we really didn't need this to
learn ourselves we feel we discovered
most of what's important for us so why
not let students discover and that's
plausible it's it's intuitively correct
but again research is counter intuitive
and it's it's you know the American
education research associated debates
for the last three years on this topic
those debates were very well attended
and by the way I think it more or less
got settled at least it was settled to
the point that the evidence now most
effectively supports that the more
support you can give students in a
guided way the more effectively they
will learn there's still people that
disagree with it I wish them well and I
encourage their research and you realize
one of the questions I recommended we
look at is that particular question sir
yes I was curious that you lumped in
procedural knowledge to things that from
my perspective as a physics education
researcher really seemed to be different
and that is the the procedure which i
think you called the how namely you know
well you have the energy conservation
equation and then you put the variables
in and you okay and then the wind too it
seems to me that what is really
difficult is the strategic all rity chiq
you know approach how do you figure out
which of these previous 12 chapters you
know whether it's Newton's laws or
energy or momentum which of them applies
at this new problem that's where I think
the students may be fairly proficient at
the components but they can't figure out
which one to use and so I'm surprised
you just lump them together is the
research that that separates them
actually the suggestion was that if you
can't figure out what sequence things
should be taught in if I understand your
question that think about which things
would be easier for students to learn
and teach those things first within a
problem within an area that's what
really was what you were focusing on
where you have a number of things you
want to teach so what do you teach first
well usually when you're solving
problems in an area there are things you
do for a second and third am i right
more or less now in some areas it's not
true I understand and when it's not true
then teach them the things that are
easiest for them to learn before those
things that are more difficult give them
some successes to go on when they hit
the hard bumps in the road that was the
suggestion did I understand your
question okay which thing you teach
first but energy and momentum they're
pretty much distinct but then I have a
situation you know something the two
cars collide with a springy bumper then
I have to figure out is that momentum or
is it energy or is it both that I hope
to use to solve that problem and and
that's that's not covered in either of
the straightforward procedures the
question says he didn't have the
microphone was basically that he's
uncertain about what needs to be
addressed first when in certain kinds of
teaching certain kinds of problems homes
that fair enough no oh one thing first
or the other thing first or both
relevant together or end and that's an
IM teach them in sequence one where you
use one first one way to use one second
and one were you doing oh oh sure
can you teach that when to use those
procedures do you know well is there an
if you see because that's the thing
that's the question the if if this is
the case then you use that and if there
if it's not if you can't do the if then
you can't teach the if been so you have
to here's the usual solution to those
find an example where you do know what
the if is and the more advanced things
leave it till later think about it over
time because people who solve those
problems have solved that problem of the
if the condition under which use it and
this is one of those things that experts
by the way we find that X remember when
I said experts are only aware of thirty
percent of how they solve problems and
analyze problems it turns out that the
if part the when they use a problem
solving strategy is much more automated
than how they do it so I'm not surprised
that that a thoughtful person would be
struggling with how do I tell students
that if the condition under which they
should do something if you were solving
those problems you would probably
quickly come up with the if the
condition the when we're actually
working we weave systematized that but
it's difficult to get them to switch
from their old mindset to to to this new
mindset and and they don't transfer even
even what from one problem to another
that are so similar and and they have
difficulty in stating the plan in other
words use the result of chapter three
and then use results of chapter five to
solve this problem hook them together
that way so teaching it so that your
create clear about that and not asking
you to go to chapter 3 in chapter five
maybe one of the solutions now there's
cheese to teach it almost as a procedure
might actually be
way to go about it you know I I'm
working surgery and you wouldn't be
surprised to find out this happens in
surgery all the time as a matter of fact
brand-new surgeons we kind of know how
many mistakes and what kind they're
going to make the first year after they
gradually it's distressing but we know
and it turns out that if we spend extra
effort on the if on the when they should
do something the mistakes actually
decrease to a dramatic point so it's not
that they don't learn how to do things
turns out that they more don't learn
when and doing the wrong thing at the
wrong time can be disastrous in the
middle of a surgery so we don't want
that to happen but it's also a
disastrous and engineering and in all
applied fields basically so i'll
actually seem dave's praises here
because he has a very effective
technique for doing this and it's
applying deliberate practice to this
instead of having sorted solve a hundred
problems which will take forever you so
sort of the hundred problems and you ask
them to identify the problem solving
strategy in many cases we don't know how
to care Chrysler if serve the when do
you use a particular strategy give a
rule for that people learn that by
pattern matching and if they can
practice just that pattern matching
without having to do all the other
overhead they may be able to learn that
more effectively there's a variety of
ways around this issue and I that's
that's certainly one of them I also well
I didn't make it part of this talk any
of you curious about these issues I want
a director to a new literature that's
very exciting it's called cognitive task
analysis cognitive task analysis it's a
way to extract from top experts that's
seventy percent of the decision rules
the mental activities they have that you
can't directly observe when they do
something so that you more easily pull
it into a course to teach it every field
expertise in every field is highly
automated and unconscious and when
experts then intend to tell students
everything they know about how to do
something they can't because they
literally can do it but they don't they
can't remember how they do it they can
even watch themselves do it but they you
can't look in your own mind and know
what's automated
so the bottom line here is that we have
to find ways to extract this we've done
a lot of work at this at our Center we
published a number of chapters and books
on it kenco nagar at the learn lab and
the PSL see the pittsburgh science of
learning center has now invested in a
huge program to try to automate some of
the cognitive task analysis strategies
for example by giving experts program
problems on the computer and having the
computer store the sequence they go
through to solve a problem and then try
to reconstruct the sequence with
different experts in the same field and
arrive at some kind of a gold standard
description of how these kinds of
problems are typically solved by people
that are consistently successful in
solving them that then is in a form that
can more easily be pushed into a course
and be more highly effective for
students increases their movement
towards expertise so much faster than
simply struggling with a problem and
deliberately practicing in that in that
expertise development sequence that we
know about I yeah yes one more question
sure you talked about how it takes too
long to do experiments what's are you
talked about how it takes a year and a
half to run a study and instead we
should be doing it much much faster so
it's contrasting that with some place
where you do run steady is much faster
so for instance if you look at how you
wear websites right you are able to run
experiments in a matter of minutes maybe
our hours at the most and what I see
from those experiments is that they
don't really seem to build a lot of
science they seem to build a lot of
point knowledge about well if I make the
button bigger here then I have more
sales at the end of the day but there
isn't much of a generalizable knowledge
so I'm wondering if the fact that you
can run experiments faster encourages
people not to generalize and instead to
say well it it differs everywhere so you
know we can't generalize anything those
are just searched scifil comments I some
some evaluation is local you're doing it
just simply learn something about the
course that you've designed for a
particular group of people
but some research has to be
international has to be for everybody we
have to find ways to take these quick
experiments that we do and ensure that
they're well-designed and capture the
results and share them that's a big data
is a great idea and I'm totally
supportive of it but big data it has big
challenges in terms of how to summarize
what we've learned from that big data
and exchange in ways that it's going to
be useful to everybody there's another
challenge for us and commitment
livelihood thank you very much for your
thank you